hello everybody
markiplier here back with more SCP
containment breach
alright going all out on this one who is
that my saver who's that no I don't know
I don't know about these guys it was
probably a bad oh not here haha ho-ho
why did I have to spawn here is my least
favorite place to spawn
oh right there I can see him I can see
like he's right in the doorway he's
right in the doorway what am I supposed
to do about that
oh alright
balls to the wall let's see here - right
there see you
I can't get around him Oh what am I
gonna do with what are we gonna do what
am I gonna do oh my god ow
he doesn't move he's just standing there
blink you think maybe if I go away and
come back we'll go away oh I don't I got
you in my son don't you I know
hahaha good a damn door hold on you
brick got you son of a hey oh my god
let's go oh my god let's just you let's
go on blink and then Freddie's bridge
don't be here guy oh I made it
oh yeah I made it through one room over
the door readily bleep in there oh oh
man
why
I heard that right there not where are
you where are you son of a [ __ ] hi girl
I know you're not
Oh God everything Wow
I saved right there no oh there we go
what is this what is this what is this
what is this oh no oh no who know those
pocket dimensions Oh No
what dellwo Zappa oh that down burn note
in accordance with our new safety
protocol SPO to end the personnel access
the personal access codes are changed at
random intervals every two to four weeks
for whenever necessary and the new
security codes are delivered to the
personal lockers at Section C and sealed
envelopes dr. George Maynard your new
personal access code is for 671 you find
the seal bro to be broken on the
envelope or the envelope tampered in any
way please contact security immediately
and you will see a new code
I'm in a one there the other SCPs sent
me into a uh-huh it to uh
pocket dimension I can't see anything oh
my oh no whoa oh I can't see oh I see
section Wow one day I died
I got pushed off something I don't even
know
ah this is the worst seed just wanted
ever ever ever can't be taken
can't see anything I'll give you there
there look at app like pick a doorway I
didn't get that note again
oh I'm fine is that it the burn note
didn't seem to work out so well for me
like save
I don't know what the mechanics of this
are whoa what them what ah that was the
wrong choice I was obviously the wrong
choice oh I'll kill this
I wish I could see what is getting
because I can't see anything is so dark
well no that was wrong not wrong I saw
what happened that film I fell in that
one nice I saw I saw nice I think yes
such so maybe it's the one with the burn
note maybe that was something and I just
got to keep going that way I think I got
it
oh what's that have kiss have what
okay whoa what southern help me I can't
jump what am I gonna do oh my oh my oh
my oh my I'm not gonna say because I
don't know if this like correct what is
going on I don't even know it's like a
little ledge down there whoa what hello
ha ha what are you what are you I see
you what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing man man what
are you doing walking slow-mo like like
you dig it do I do
what do I do
what do i do man to tell me what to do
ah what done what huh where ha
I died somehow oh I'm gonna be stuck in
this pocket dimension forever okay so
whatever it is I think that's kind of
the right way I'm supposed to go I'm not
sure maybe this tells me you have your
eyes up adjusted yet oh oh oh that's
right oh so that's what happens the eyes
need to adjust to the darkness
what this is new same here this is new
wall they're on something's going on I
might be able to get out of here
eyes adjusting
can't see anything oh don't tell me I
think I know yep I dyed it fudge fudge
nuggets badge nuggets I don't know
what's going on if you guys know what oh
no oh I think I spawned it fell oh no my
little posh in the same they're up and a
crash yep I I screwed up bad I screwed
up on that one memory access violation I
don't know guys I don't know I don't
know it all I I I am not doing very well
this game as you can see I'm bad at it
so hopefully you guys can forgive me for
that
I don't know I don't know I just don't
know
don't kick getting back into it and
hitting dad fraps button now okay
hopefully that low data backup I'm gonna
try load it once if it doesn't work I'm
just gonna have to start a new game
again I'm getting better at though I'd
like get through the first level I
should be fine okay no I felt all right
gotta start a new game
Martin Mac reply that's exactly
markiplier bone or what
oh no I actually misspelled phone and
said own so weird
sable the intro let's go alright I'm
gonna try to breakneck speed through
what we got Oh
man I don't know what that other SCP was
if you guys know please write in the
comments I'd like to read up on that
because I find that stuff interesting I
do like to read it someday I'd like to
light my own yeah there we go
save let's go
probably gonna be NSEP up nope okay okay
okay so so far is okay close the door
behind me
so far link yeah we're good
sprint sprint we're good so far what is
this oh this looks new shave here take a
gas mask off actually see ah more notes
a sec 860 see it's a key object is inert
dark blue key can fit any door that
requires a key located in the area that
given coordinates interesting probably
telling me that there's a key around
here that I can find that can help me
out
what's that what the hell no way awesome
another map navigator ah was that what
was that
level one key card perfect oh this this
is the best okay finally I'm gonna
actually make some progress here guys
eight nine five I saw a sign for that
before stored in an isolated underground
containment cell at a depth of
approximately a hundred meters no camera
microphones or other surveillance
equipment may be brought within 10 meter
red zone radius or SCP aids in 9/5
without expressed permission from at
least two level 3 personnel
it's an ornate wood oak coffin recovered
from the mortuary by SCP personnel
following reports of unusual footage
captured by surveillance equipment
installed at that location upon
attempting to open scp-896 empty
however observers viewing the live
camera feet were data expunged I'm a
super chilled SC p 9 5 must remain
closed
at all times Wow I got a read that a CP
because that sounds like an awesome one
Oh guys these are there's a lot of cool
stuff on the SCP website if you don't
know what it is I will try to provide a
link in this description here because
there are some cool stuff in there let
me tell you I think I saw this once when
I play disorder Savings back Stickley
what was that holy hell yeah actually
how did timing I'm gonna oh god I'm
going back to the office seems like the
only safe area I've found so far so I'm
gonna go game said okay how many pauses
so Homme anomalisa man this game is like
we fix it but I'm actually making some
progress now hopefully can get Delta
game is paused the game is paused okay
hopefully we can actually delve down
deeper into the secrets of scpi 7 o
menos sweating anyway thank you all so
much for watching if you like to see it
please let me know because I want to
continue this but I don't know how long
I'm gonna continue it so it's up to you
guys as long as I'm still being scared I
guess I can keep playing and as long as
it's still stuff to discover I guess
I'll keep playing so thank you all so
much for watching and as always see you
in the next part
bye bye